[Music]
you made it weird with Pete Holmes
what's happening weirdos this is Rick
Glassman who is hilarious a riff machine
and a very very interesting and fun to
talk to person I know this because I've
been a guest on his podcast which is
called take your shoes off twice and
both were incredibly incredibly fun and
wonderful riff filled chat so we were
due for a silly one this is a silly one
and I'm so glad Rick was able to join us
for the first time here on you made it
weird here is a little taste of our
conversation I wrongly wrongly felt
everybody feels about me positively
which was great for my self-worth I I
love myself I'm fun I'm funny
I'm phenomenal
and then I found out I'm not and by that
I mean I became aware that oh there's a
possibility that people think
differently than me not that they think
differently to me I disagreed there's a
possibility
all right weirdos lots lots to enjoy
here if you'd like to come and see me
live which I would love so many weirdos
have been coming out on the road and it
means so much to see you guys in person
and to do stand up for you which is
obviously my first my first love if you
guys want to see me here's where I'm
going to be this uh well I was just in
Vancouver coming up next is Grand Rapids
San Diego New Orleans Dallas Houston
Milwaukee Madison Royal Oak Michigan
Minneapolis New York New York and
Ridgefield Connecticut
for tickets to all of those go to
petehomes.com I also do a monthly show
in Los Angeles if you're going to be in
the Los Angeles area go to
largo-l-a.com and you'll see a show
called Pete Holmes living at Largo it's
once a month uh last month was on
Valentine's Day was so fun it's always a
highlight of my month so if you're going
to be in the California area or I guess
it's a big state the Los Angeles area go
to largo-la.com and we would love to see
you at that show I say we because Val is
almost always there which is so so fun
and if you like this show the way it
works is I try always to pick sponsors
that I actually use and actually love
like here I'm going to stand up perfect
Jane
if you're not watching on video that
made no sense I'm wearing my perfect
jeans you know why I'm always wearing
perfect jeans
the perfect Jean I have this pair of
jeans after I discovered the perfect
Jean basically in four different colors
and and a couple different pairs of each
because once I found these pans there
was no going back they have done it the
boys at the perfect Gene have discovered
the perfect fit the perfect cut the
perfect wash and just a little bit of
stretch I hate hard pants and these are
the best pants I've ever owned I
literally haven't looked back I wear
them to fancy Hollywood things because
they look like designer jeans I've taken
naps in them because they're soft like
pajamas they're incredible they're not
like super soft in the sense that
they're they're not like flannel PJs
they're still identifiable as jeans but
two percent spandex 2.5 rayon for extra
comfort and movement that your man Parts
require that means these jeans stretch
so your nuts ain't crushed it doesn't
crush your nuts thereby providing the
only true home for your bone they're
super soft specialized washing so your
jeans literally feel as soft as a baby's
butt and they're incredibly durable I've
been wearing them for years and you do
not have to replace these pans regular
jeans they always wear out in the middle
tear up in the crotch area not perfect
jeans not only does the rayon and the
spandex that they sew into this stuff
make it stretchier and more comfortable
but it makes it more durable but it's
also high quality materials and sewing
techniques that give you a product that
is built to last so once you buy one of
these
you're set best of all they're not
khakis [__] your khakis and spare your
nuts the perfect Gene for the Perfectly
Imperfect man just 60 bucks when you use
code weirdo at checkout liberate your
lower limbs with the one and only
perfect Gene whether you're working with
lemons or lentils a three leaf clover or
a big old honk an eggplant the perfect
Gene has you covered take a peek at
www.theperfectgene.nyc that's the
perfect
gene.nyc code weirdo for 25 off at
checkout incredible get into it do your
body a favor look good feel good and
show your support of the show another
Pete's pick that I always have here on
my desk for those of you watching the
video
this is Magic mind the biggest game
changer of this year for me for sure has
been magic mine what is it it is not an
energy drink it's a productivity drink
it doesn't get you jittery it doesn't
get you wired it gets you in the flow
it's like a flow state beverage you know
how athletes have Gatorade now creative
types have creatorade it's a magical
Elixir that makes you focus better on
your work be more creative and you drink
less coffee in fact I take this with my
espresso in the morning it has
adaptogens that help round off the edge
of the caffeine that I get from my
espresso giving me a dialed in clean
energy there's also about 35 milligrams
of caffeine in here because of the
matcha that helps you focus and the
adaptogens help you fight off stress you
can take it daily for a sharper mind
steady energy immune support and like I
said less stress you've got 30 more done
on average that's five to seven hours of
thirty percent more productivity after
drinking it is the Creator's best friend
I try I take it about 15 minutes before
I go on stage before I'm writing a
script before I'm doing a podcast I
often give it to the guests as you see
it on the show helps fight off
procrastination brain fog fatigue and
some symptoms of ADD getting you into
that flow State and the more you use it
the better it works with a money back
guarantee any first purchase will be
refunded no questions asked if it
doesn't meet your expectations and we
have a special offer for weirdos from
our friends at Magic mind all you have
to do is go to
www.magicmind.com weird and use discount
code at checkout weird for a limited 20
off your first order that's
magicmine.com weird and use promo code
weird at checkout for 20 off your first
order it's a mood elevating it dials in
gives your brain all the nutrition it
needs to focus and work or sometimes I
take it just like when I'm going out
want to have access to my brain want to
have access to energy
without feeling jittery I'm drinking way
less coffee and getting way more done
and feeling way less stress and they
just improve the taste so it's even
better so try it Go to magicmine.com
weird and show your support of the show
all right everybody let's enjoy a silly
silly fun chat with my boy Rick Glassman
get into it
really I I don't need a bathroom but I
did want to do a mirror check a mirror
yeah yeah you say mirror a mirror mirror
a mirror
um you look great sit down I'm gonna I'm
gonna look in the mirror use a phone
here you go I have one uh
yours and I accept it
that's a really funny way to address my
energy that does need to be adjusted
I'll meet you outside in eight minutes
hurry up with your phone call
I live in Ojai
like wide angle
the nice wide
and could you guys not look at me while
I do this yeah yeah
I didn't want to look at you doing your
mirror check
but now I really
this is all on there
are you kidding me this golden mirror
check
do you say robit
have we covered this do you say robit
don't mess with my camera
what are you doing
no
[Music]
no no no no
[Laughter]
you are the master of the bed Ricky
Glassman
Ricky Glassman
oh you did your writer yeah I wasn't
sure because I asked for the smallest
headphones possible but you got him
oh I see I've set the tone as acrid and
Year yes ending it
Ricky Glass what
does is that what your butthole looks
like no that's what I would say if I
were holding a mirror to your face
welcome back to the P Holmes uh you know
oh
what's this podcast you made it weird
um you did when you met me outside with
that attitude it's good to be back I
you've never been on the show I can't
hear you hold on one sec
Ricky Glassman actually I do want to do
over okay could we switch seats so I
don't have to hurt my neck
sit like I'm sitting first of all here's
a plug for your podcast
you hated that I hated it so much just
this oh don't do it again
I wanted to discern if it was a bit
um a socked foot on a on a sweater elbow
because just tell me everything
you wanted to give a plug to my podcast
your shoes off no I was going to say you
take your shoes off I could do that I
have matching socks you mean matching to
mine or you mean your two socks are
matching the socks the two socks I'm
wearing in both ways they the socks I'm
wearing my left match is my right and
they know what I mean what's my camera
that's your camera mug mug mug it up you
can also put your shoes keep your
because they're great shoes keep them on
but put them on the couch really yeah oh
I'll do this I get what is going on with
you in my foot touching your elbow
they're just downstairs feet I mean
hands
let me do the roof again yeah the Riff
I mean the arrogance on this guy
yeah an unplanned comedy attempt is a
riff yeah it doesn't sound so sexy when
you call it an unplanned comedy attempt
it wasn't that sexy of a riff two three
four has to come before a riff
they're just your downstairs hands and
and they're shocked and it's early in
the day I didn't I'm not I'm not so UPS
I'm fine I wasn't triggered by it but it
happened and it was just like if you
really don't understand why somebody
doesn't why somebody wouldn't want your
sock on their thing I think the amount
of time it would take to explain it to
you would be worth it so here's the
thing no it would be a waste of
everyone's time and I want to make a
good impression in front of your very
young female audience what is it like 23
to 27 year old females that listen to
this
or is it 39 year olds black guys because
those are the two main demographics
those are your peep those are my number
demographics those are your two demos I
think my demo is
um
I don't I don't know what my demo is I
know it's a lot of people that
most people at least the ones that reach
out have at least one of my things
what are your things well well
Judaism
I don't think that's really a thing I
thought that was definitely going to be
one of your things no only because
you're a celebrated Jewish performer
a cjp
I know you love acronyms and he moved he
wouldn't let me touch even the knee with
the foot
so um we recently talked about how uh
cjp I I want to tell you I think this is
so funny and I think you're so funny and
please stop and I don't want your foot
on me and that's okay it's not gonna
touch you okay the whole time so uh I
don't wanna
I'm aware of everything so what happened
so far is a fun moment that we've had
but it could easily Define the rest of
the podcast we could now be in this
energy and go for for better or worse
I'm just saying you mean the sock hole
the sock hole Yeah but also just the
tell me about
whatever
I'm just feeling like we don't have to
start over but let's ease in okay I love
that and then you then you take control
we're very similar you and I yeah
yeah and your socks vibe and how things
start super important to me who said
that me just now
Oh I thought it was a quote no no no I
mean it is a quote I just all you have
to do is put up put online with a
picture of of Tom Hardy and then quote
it and people it'll be on like one of
those marketing websites I see so many
quotes from things that was obviously
not Tom Hardy that's hilarious but they
just put a picture of Tom Hardy yeah
Vibe and energy checks are the way
podcasts begin and it's like a picture
of you know Tom Hardy yeah I've seen a
fair amount of them the actor
actor Bane
I don't look no offense to Tom Hardy but
I feel like you're about to say
something pretty mean to Tom Hardy I
just don't see him as like a waxing
philosophical guy I see him as like an
impressive physical specimen with like
cauliflower ear in a lot of movies
the most delicious era injury
cauliflower why aren't you miked up for
the little laughs you can we pick him up
here
all right but but to be real
maybe you can relate sometimes I observe
my own personality like there's a rope
tied to us a safe and someone pushed the
safe out the window and it's just out my
hands right and that's and I'm not upset
about it with you but just to yes and
what you're saying that's how it's been
since you texted me that you were here
but you wanted to wait for the street
cleaning to switch over to 11 A.M and I
was like I'll greet you in eight minutes
and me I'm not a bully see I'm not going
to touch you with my sock for real but
like that seemed like I thought you were
doing a bit but then the energy it's
like throwing blood in the water but
again why am I uh like incited by Blood
and what you understand what I'm saying
I'm not loving my own energy
and I'd like to join you in your invite
to reset it
I don't understand what do you mean I'm
just kidding you just were talking about
that is blood in the water and rope it's
very hard you didn't get the Rope thing
you seem like a guy that would be like
each other's sentences people
that are like let's start over know
about the safe rope feeling
were you just like what is happening why
am I being this way
um why am I making fun of how you say
mirror right off the bat yeah that let's
I think I think um
it might be because our Dynamic is very
bit heavy and you heard an unusual thing
yeah why and
the letter Y
vhy because you said yeah
f
d y s y
so I think I think you were just looking
for a bit yeah which should be the name
of your podcast looking for a bit
if you and I ever did a podcast together
um it would be called looking for a bit
and I think the theme music would be
very quick it would open up with uh
oh God
sorry looking for a bit Ah looking for a
bit all right guys guys let's go looking
for a bit is brought to you by
Squarespace do you have a Squarespace
sponsor no I never do we never did
Square maybe 10 years ago we did
Squarespace you need help yeah it's been
this is my podcast take off your jacket
is that a jerk off sound
yeah
I don't know I don't know
can I say this
when this is the first time
I've recorded the intro for this episode
before we did the episode but was the
intro this you guys today was crazy we
had Rick over and we talked about basket
ball Tom Hardy and Marshall Ford
whatever
what do you think of the movie
basketball I don't remember it very well
but whenever I do a random call to a
movie basketball is one of those things
yeah that's a good one except nobody did
people see basketball I don't think
anybody saw it you don't get to the Book
of Mormon everyone celebrated genius
Masterwork without basketball that's
what that's my Tom Hardy quote right
yeah and I don't get to them you make a
weird basketballs before Book of Mormon
go ahead
timing passed I think it's over
you know just I just I'm I'm now ready
I'm now ready okay to begin yeah I'm now
here with you what I was gonna say was
yeah okay
who's gonna say what it should have
started right now okay welcome to the
show in the intro that I already
recorded I said we were due for a silly
one yeah because every time I'm with you
it's silly beans Galore isn't the most
stuff with you silly beans not always
there's a lot of episodes where people
might go like is this guy silly beans
itgsb
because I'm not hearing silly beans
b-i-n-hsb
sometimes K is hard when it's like no a
lot of times I mess them up but it's
just because I don't know how to spell
the word
a-o-t-i-m-s-o-u no yeah yeah a lot of
times I mess them up oh play the tape
back I thought you were doing what I did
I didn't know you did acronyms I have
acronym breaks I thought you were doing
it because you know I do it I watched a
thing in my research for you and learned
things I didn't know even though I've
done your podcast twice and I know you I
didn't know even though you were Jewish
until I didn't even know you were a Jew
what did you watch do you research it's
weird I will start with Wikipedia but
that's just the base coat I just got a
Wikipedia like a week ago you know what
I'll do after that
YouTube is
and I sometimes just type in I am
phenomenal did you watch I am phenomenal
what's that we'll cut to a clip because
I think Rick Glassman has this great
photo of him playing against LeBron
James in high school which is just an
insane thing now I heard he's really
good Rick's really good if somebody told
me that like he was I think playing a
pickup game with someone like somebody
in entertainment and they're like hey
man like you gotta dial it back a little
bit hit that Baldy
you're not aware of how other people
perceive you what are you talking about
good thank you idiot
whoops
[__] nuts I am phenomenal I got big
balls I got a cool guy haircut I got and
we're back is that your stand-up special
I made a little uh character piece about
me being a phenomenal basketball player
but lacking awareness and I think I'm
the best and but I find out that people
don't want to play with me
how much of that is true and or real
um it's it's I play a more a heightened
version of myself but I was in a
basketball game with uh an old boss in
front of mine who sent me an email to
say a lot of the guys in the game don't
like playing with you and Bill Lawrence
wrote this email uh and he uh I was
kicked out of the game for a little and
then wait tell me everything uh Joel
McKay so I Joel McHale played Bill more
like Kevin McHale no comment when he's
on the court yeah but he was Joel and uh
F and
um the script the script was Bill's
email w b e
the script was Bill's email yeah so the
email that bill sent me that was kicked
me out of the game then I gave to Joel
for the script and the things that Joel
was saying to me or the character I was
playing was straight from that email oh
and Joel was sort of playing Bill
Lawrence yeah so why who did out of the
game
I wanted to acknowledge one thing real
quick
um I have talked about this on my
podcast and a few other podcasts when
this came out
um which is fine but I'm feeling I don't
know if insecure is the right word but
it's in the family of like oh I'm
talking about this thing again now I
don't think that we should have the same
audience necessarily but I am just
feeling like oh I don't need to be
talking too much about this but I also
can I just wanted to say that does that
make sense you you don't want to be
embarrassed as the guy who's always you
know when they do those Super Cuts Jimmy
kimmelon live did a super cut of Lady
Gaga every time he was on a late night
shows telling the same story I'm like
that's not fair Vin Diesel is just an
actor he's not like you know what I mean
he's he's not a comedian writing his own
stuff and switching it up so he's going
out of course he's also on a promo tour
that's what I mean yeah and there and
people ask the same question people
still ask me is crashing about your real
life and I still give like the same
reflexive answer I try to mix it up a
little bit but you could make a super
cut of that meaning there's no shame in
repeating yourself yeah I don't feel
ashamed I just wanted to acknowledge a
feeling where like my instinct is to not
talk about it but it's fine to talk
about it but if I don't acknowledge that
I'll be thinking about it I understand
but now can I introduce this there's no
way this posture from us is flattering
the way we're sitting the way we're
sitting with these camera angles like
this here
yeah I'd agree with that do you think
you're you know we first started talking
and we'll get back to whatever because
people will be like finish but we talked
about YouTube yeah and like you you know
the audio numbers are a lot higher than
the YouTube yeah and to make the YouTube
a certain way you we we do want to focus
on making things
pretty look better yes and you think
this is note number one I think that
this uh unless this is by design a way
that you feel makes people comfortable
and or like literally close yeah which
helps you get something out of the guest
yeah I think you know yeah because I'm
with you but when I did your podcast
Counterpoint I felt very far I'll take
your shoes off I know what it's called I
thought you called the Counterpoint
I thought you were saying when I did
your podcast Counterpoint no
Counterpoint to the point you just made
first I'm sitting a goodly length yeah
from you and I'm like I don't like this
I feel like I'm on the spot I feel like
I'm in some sort of hot seat right like
it's like a presidential debate and
you're asking me questions I'm not going
to touch you but I like being able to
touch you right and I like the feeling
of a sleepover and I like that it's
dumping there's a way of of staying
close
yeah we used to do it at a table and we
did it on the same corner and we were
very close I I I've been thinking how
much I want a table or a desk because
there's a desk confidence that you have
that you could have yeah put your hands
solid yeah I do like that but then
Hassan Minaj did it and he kept slapping
the table so sometimes you're just
giving them something to slap yeah but
it's a different culture okay
[Music]
I don't know if that's one of the
pre-approved uh stereotypes of East
Asians is that they know and then people
from The Daily Show because they're so
professional very funny you're very
funny you're a talented man thank you
um but I'm with you Mike Birbiglia my
dear friend he texted me was like your
show looks like [__] he's like I hate
watching your show I like to make it
look better I could we could great yeah
you think that's why our YouTube number
stuck is because people turn it on they
go like well this doesn't look very nice
no I just think that if people looked at
it and were attracted to it it would be
more attractive it's just as simple as
that I understand yeah no there's a
certain uh frumpiness to my personality
that I'm not upset by but I'm also not
thrilled by right it's also like
you know I'm just not a very aesthetic
person and when you know really
aesthetic people like I'm friends with
Darren McGee and he's real fun wow on
Instagram and he's a brilliant artist
and he also dresses really well and we
go our kids go to the same school and
whenever he sees me and Darren listens
to the show so it's not like oh no
Darren's gonna hear this uh he'll often
notice how like thrown together I look
right because he's a looks person and
I'm not really a super looks person yeah
maybe it would help that you're this is
a nice backdrop though this is from the
paint home show it's a fairy tale
hashtag defensive you know um looks
versus style slash vibe to associate
those the same thing it makes me think
of like when people who who think that
like
diet and Wellness
is like is different than the way you
look like I didn't do a good job
explaining that
look look meaning a certain type of uh a
certain type of look a classical beauty
or a or a or a professional looking set
or whatever
it doesn't have to be a certain kind of
look but I believe there should be an
intention to it so even if it's frumpy
or the back house or like you know like
the Wayne's World basement yeah but like
to have a reason an intention and lean
into that thing I I think you're right
it we could have a little bit more of a
feel of like someone thought this
through instead of this is the only
place the couch would fit right which is
fine for Audio Only yeah that's right
okay so it is I hope maybe this is
interesting to people that are trying to
get on YouTube because we started
putting this show on YouTube and I
noticed you started your show in 2019 so
it's relatively new yes sir
um just to maybe let it connect to even
more people because I think this is this
isn't about a YouTube show yeah only
this is about intention which travels
way bigger than a YouTube show but it
just completely agree well done that's
right that's really right on and one of
the things I struggle with meaning I
have to be deliberate about in my life
is uh purpose mission statement why I'll
get blue if I lose my why if that makes
sense blue as in sad or blue dirty
not a Blue Streak not like a Sinatra
being like I like your comedy axon but
it has a Blue Streak about that okay
that's a very old term yeah I didn't
know what I meant blue like like talking
about penises and farts that's what yeah
Blue Streak blue blue blue comes from
Blue Streak I believe
Soldier
sold you as I told you oh you and Katie
were talking about that earlier yeah
anyway thank you so the show isn't so
much that it's from a dump it's that
it's lacking vision and and I'm agreeing
with you people pick up on that and go
like there isn't a lot of intention here
and we're attracted to intention as well
why why why am I gonna watch it
because we're having an interesting good
conversation that I'll just listen
yeah I suppose
some see the reason we went on YouTube
was people just told me like everybody
goes to YouTube for their podcast now so
I was just like oh let's throw it on
maybe they're not even watching it it's
just one of the windows that's open and
they're listening to it maybe they look
at it every once in a while who cares I
just wanted more people to hear because
I'm very proud of the show yeah but then
to to bring us into the Genesis of this
conversation that you and I have been
having
I was shocked people have since
described what the algorithm is and
everything because I have I have like
800 000 subscribers and then we uploaded
the first episode and we struggled to
get 20 000 yeah views and that was with
Maya Rudolph that episode now has 250
000 views but it's taken a really long
time then we put up are you trying to
[__] me a little bit
does that sound like a brag I was joking
okay like my Maya Rudolph episode is 250
000 now it's like oh I didn't think this
was a bragging struggling who thought
that with 800 subscribers you'd get
eight like not 800 but easily the week
it came out we thought oh this is going
to be great A lot of people are going to
see it yeah I actually thought I was
being vulnerable
subscriber doesn't mean [__] subscribers
doesn't mean that they're going to even
see it let alone want to watch content
that's different it used to be that way
somebody told me before covid
pre-covered yeah what do you mean
before covid your subscribers would see
it and since cover they went out I was
smoking with you I told you I didn't
know if they changed their policy I
don't know when the algorithm started
but it used to be that if you subscribe
to somebody and they dropped a new video
it would show up in your feed and that
is no longer true it's one of the
multiple variables that exist so if I
subscribe to you and I watched one of
your things and it wrecked they would
probably recommend another one if I
clicked on it it would maybe keep
recommending it I see but if I don't
subscribe to you and I watch one of your
things it might not necessarily
recommend one of your videos as much as
it would recommend another podcast
interesting so it's just like you want
to have them subscribe to you you want
them to click on your stuff you want
them to stay for a decent amount of time
you want them to like and comment and
engage it's just there's a lot of things
yeah that's the stuff that isn't really
it's not what I signed up for you know
either I only learned it because I do it
but it's my my intention is to have
something
feels special to me like this is how I
see it this is how I want to do it and
I'm happy to say it's been working my my
Rudolph episode has 300 000 views so I
mugged the camera for those watching for
the 15 people watching I mugged to the
camera I feel like you only need to tell
the people who aren't watching yeah
that's right that was for the audio
people but I'm like yeah I just mugged
to the camera um but uh I wanna I wanna
take a little control here because you
and I must make a pact uh we'll take
control whether it's my podcast of yours
yeah sure um let's get off the YouTube
okay track I feel like I feel like we
needed a little bit of it
because you think the show looks like
[__]
which is interesting and helpful
I'm the guy that if I have spinach in my
teeth please tell me so you're a friend
I use that analogy I say with a booger
just there we are we're both together
have you ever almost died there you go
there's a good question for Ricky Glass
can I talk about the spinach and the
teeth thing
I did a comedy show the other day stand
up
and 250 000 people watched it no it was
at the Hollywood improv okay and
um one of the hosts uh they were lovely
people one of them doesn't do stand-up
um and uh she brought me up and she
handed me the microphone which is fine I
it's best to put it in the mic stand
what if I don't want to hold it not a
big deal I just noticed it and like if
she doesn't do it much and then I saw
her bringing up somebody else and she
also had she handed it so I had uh uh my
thought process was I used to always
tell people things I thought that I
would want to know for example a booger
in my nose
what I've learned is for for reasons
even outside of this example but
something I literally tell myself as a
tool now Rick you don't know everybody
your truth you don't have to tell
everybody everything that's true that's
how you get kicked out of basketball
games like I'm not even trying to be
funny it's guys like us that are earnest
and eager that sometimes put people off
I've been booted out of church small
groups do you know how go to a clip
you know how offensive and too much you
have to be to be asked to not show up to
a Bible study so I'm just I didn't want
you to think I was teasing you People
Like Us yeah well-meaning puppy-like
energy sometimes overstep boundaries we
didn't even know we were overstepping
yeah boundaries uh not written or
subscribed to by us that's right but
it's important to recognize kind of some
Global boundaries that exist so like you
know if you go to a new country find out
some of their their rules you know yeah
there you go
um and uh I thought I want to tell her
because I would want somebody to tell me
but that's something I say all the time
I'm like I would have wanted to know but
I think that's the rule to go by but the
thing is like you could always tell
somebody something later yeah so but
then you're like I'm thinking about it
and then it becomes embarrassing that
you're still thinking about it you're
like hey the other night right yeah is
that what you mean well I'm not
embarrassing but yeah but just like if
it's on my mind but that's another thing
I think like if I still think about this
the next day or in an hour whatever the
give it a cool off period yeah if you're
still thinking about it but uh I told I
told her
and I think she received a friend she's
like oh thanks for for telling me but I
I was aware of something that has
happened to me a fair amount of times
which is
oh maybe I shouldn't have said anything
but
and and it's not for right or wrong it's
just different people but like
the reason I when I feel like I
shouldn't have said anything isn't
because I feel like this person
shouldn't have known nor was it that I
didn't want to be the person to say I
feel fine about saying it it's entirely
based off of their response right like
for example if people don't know us and
they're watching the show because they
uh they randomly come up to and they
don't know either of us and you put your
sock on me and I go oh and I get mad at
you and then you go you get weird
it's a weird vibe but if I go oh I get
mad at you and then you are playful and
joke back everything's fine right I did
the same thing it's just your reaction I
can't control your reaction
but sometimes you tell people something
like you have spinach in your teeth yeah
and now they don't they're they I can't
be around Pete he's right always making
me feel insecure right and it's like
right
so the people that want somebody that
would tell me I have spinach in my teeth
we like these people well it's I know
that they would want me to say you have
a boogerinos this is me and Mike
Birbiglia I've said this many times Mike
is the guy that if I really want to know
what someone thinks about my special or
this joke or whatever he'll tell me and
that's how we are we we sometimes we sat
around and been like what do people say
uh behind my back and we just tell each
other
oh people will speak poorly about you to
him no well you know you just hear by
virtue of not being the person right
you're privy to what are the areas of
the Rifts if you're making fun of me
yeah you know when I said I was like
people say you're like an NPR guy like
oh this is American life kind of like is
that an insult yeah if if you're like a
if you're trying to be like a
hard-hitting
45 minutes of just
you don't want to be the guy that's like
and now a story about my surgery and I
love mine and that is in my opinion an
even higher bar to reach for but some
Comics I do here make fun of Mike for
being like an hourglass kind of
[__] and he's like people say
you're too much you're tone deaf you
barge into situations you say the wrong
thing right all that but that's helpful
it's helpful to have the spinach and the
teeth friend that's what I'm saying I'm
agreeing but I think you did the right
thing because where but stand-up comedy
do you need someone right to give just a
little bit of a [__] to say hey I know
this doesn't really seem like something
you would know which is why I'm telling
you put the mic in the stand and let the
comedian decide if they want to
understand but stand is default yeah
Stan is default and some people like me
with my sock in your foot maybe I don't
want to touch the microphone directly
from your hand there's something about
the neutral space that busy I want to
pull up the stool and not have to deal
with it that's right it's just a I
adjust the mic stand and then I take it
out it's it's you know what it is and
this is very apropos what we were
talking about earlier Judd apropos is
Chad apropos it's a chat apropos
production it's a mod apropos production
production is it's a little bit of
ownership over the space so a stand-up
comedian is going up on stage and they
want to set their tone and their flavor
that's why we move the stool that's why
we move the stand and when you're
handing me a microphone you're giving me
a receiving first choice yeah now I am a
receiver it's like when you wake up in
the morning and the first thing you do
is answer emails get the [__] out of
here that's like receiving a microphone
being handed to you from an emcee I want
in the stand I'll take it out when I
want you know why because stand-up
comedy is the hardest thing in the world
to do it's one of them I mean as a
performance that and being a mother
that's why I said as a performance
well that's my mother performance
there's no bigger performer than her cut
to a clip
but the idea of of uh of telling people
things that you would want to know yes
is one of the definitions of the Golden
Rule but that's it but but people hate
it sometimes yeah and and you know I've
I'm not gonna I have another example of
this which is which is a confusing one
because like I am aware of you know
choosing moments that are like is this
important
um a good friend of mine in fact one of
my best friends got some blood work
taken and let's just say his cholesterol
is high
and you know what I'm saying it's
cholesterol it's a cholesterol and
um I uh I'm conscious of the things I'm
eating and of blood work and hormones
and looking into stuff and
um he even asked me like what am I
allowed to eat what am I supposed to eat
and I was helping with some ideas and
things and uh this was a few months ago
uh we were together recently and going
out to eat and uh he was he got he
ordered his food and then some like
chips and some stuff come and greasy and
blah blah blah and I said uh
eat whatever you want I just in case I
just want to let you know that like
these these are some of the things that
are bad for a cholesterol I really would
I just want you to know when I do this
I'm touching you with my foot because
often on the show I'm touching somebody
with my foot when I'm like this is
hilarious like I love it okay and I just
want you to know
like eat whatever you want just know
these are some of the things they eat
whatever you want thing I say first is
is my shorthand of of letting you know
I'm not telling you what to do I'm
trying to provide information and also
no judgment you're saying we're friends
yeah we're friends zero judgment zero
judgment but they didn't feel it a
different way that's right so you say
neutral these are some of the things so
I said it and he goes oh okay uh and I
didn't think much of it
um and then there was uh another
situation that happened the same day
with something with ice cream or
whatever now mind you this is the first
time I ever did this I don't know why I
didn't do it before or I didn't think
about it
this was the first time I'm not like
always like don't eat don't eat like
that could maybe get annoying especially
if the person isn't receiving it saying
thanks or telling me right but I said it
I said two things and
um my mom the performer was also there
and um by the way in case there's any
stigma to that uh my mom like my mom's
the best I love my mom
um she's hilarious but I'm about to say
something that isn't me so like I want
to make sure I'm not like
anyway who cares
um interesting but my mom goes like let
him eat what he wants
which I would also be like yeah if like
I felt somebody was trying to control
someone but I'm like I'm not stopping
him from eating what he wants you know
like that's happening inside yeah yeah
but I'm like all right yeah yeah but I
feel like as your lawyer thank you with
your foot
because we might need a different symbol
okay this means I'm tapping you how
about this means as your lawyer because
we already established the one finger as
your lawyer yes did say to you a fitment
you look like I want to ask you what
you're eating you're a fitman uh thank
you Jewish I don't know what that has to
do with it rick fitman
f
uh
are you turning on and off the lights
she's telling me this doesn't look great
on YouTube I'm fine with that
this is why people Tune In by the dozens
um listen as your lawyer he did break
the seal of saying hey right my
cholesterol is high
what do you know about that right a
couple months ago as soon as you do that
maybe you're open to say it's saturated
fat right saturated fat is what's
[__] with your cholesterol
um yeah but also I I don't know enough
about what fats are fats because also uh
you know
um sugar does it as well so I'm not
exactly sure but I think saturated fat
is the is probably the main thing yeah
um fries and red meats and and uh yeah
uh but I brought this up to him and then
I didn't like it and your mom scolded
you uh my mom was just did she just
called me she's like letting me it was
nothing
um and uh
later I was having a conversation with
my friend about something unrelated uh
to the cholesterol stuff
and then
he gave an example for to contextualize
to bring it about us like well for
example when you said this about the
cholesterol and I go
is that something you don't want me to
you that bothered you he goes well you
know I I I I I decided I want to eat it
and I didn't want to you know like when
you when you said that it made me feel
like
judged and maybe I shouldn't be eating
that judge dapatel uh mono you said
something mono that I didn't get mono
rewind it you mean it only came in one
of your earphones no you I said uh Judd
Apple pro at the pro and then you said
monoappapro mod approach yeah I don't
know I didn't know what mod meant his
daughter mod Apatow oh shout out to
Modern put her Instagram handle here
yeah she's weak and I joke she's bigger
is that a name drop 250 on Maya personal
anecdote with Judd now I'm sensitive how
many how many are does Judd have how
many what views or listens it's never
been on YouTube
um I do a bit on YouTube are you gonna
have them back I'd love to come back
that's a very good Judd yeah mod defy
your voice a little lower
uh I'm gonna close out this this this
story I feel great about this story and
as as the host and your friend I am also
keeping tabs on where you are in the
story you're in a safe place
I love this story
he said I wanted to eat that food and I
didn't feel great about how you
corrected me and and your mom didn't
scold you and I said to him feels a
little judgy uh I said
um
yeah I won't I won't do that again
if we didn't have this conversation
about this unrelated thing I wouldn't
have known that because yeah
um I'm like why wouldn't you tell me
that because I I didn't want to make a
you know
the so me I'm someone who's saying you
have spinach in your teeth he didn't
like it yeah he is somebody who doesn't
like it is not somebody who's willing to
tell you that you have spinach in your
teeth so he didn't even want to tell me
he didn't like it right so now it's like
now we're all we're all mind leaving the
blind so Rick what did you do wrong
knowing what you know now by wrong I
mean what could you have done
differently I understand um don't tell
him this thing what did he do wrong
didn't set up his boundaries I
I did everything I would have wanted
somebody to do for me and would be
willing to receive
critic criticism on how to do it
differently yes
didn't and I'm thinking now defensive
yep
that's on you pal it is on you can I can
I interject with a comparison
buddy I'm a polite person I like being
polite oh yeah it's a little indication
that you're not lost in your animal
brain you're here you're in society
you're being kind you're being measured
measured
but Ricky G
if I am in a Starbucks and I open the
door and it's unlocked bathroom door and
someone's in there I don't say sorry
lock that door that's on you
I go oh
excuse me but I don't say sorry it's
like I don't thank people for taking my
money at tolls I go have a good day but
I don't say thank you I would have
preferred you not been here
these are exaggerations but if somebody
is in the bathroom and the door does
lock it's always some Alpha guy peeing
all over the floor it always throw a
lock on it
I'm exaggerating I probably do
reflection but I am thinking like that's
on you because I go in the lock works
I'm like I get the bathroom one more
than the tall one do you like saying it
thank you I don't drive to places with
tolls it's a thing of mine but you're an
Easy Pass guy no I don't I I'm just
joking I just can't remember the last
time I did it I was with you because
you're living in a more pure and honest
and open world
like an open world video game where if
something bothers me we're hoping that
someone will say something but we don't
live in that world I was just listening
to Ethan suplee on a on a podcast and he
was talking about doing a hot yoga class
and they were like there's one rule you
can't leave if you if you're tired lie
down but you can't leave the room right
and he was laying down and his heart was
jacked and he thought he was gonna die
and he was like I'm gonna die because
this woman has a rule and I was like
that's really funny and that's how human
beings are we would rather die often
than be socially uncomfortable right so
I I also want to throw this back at you
but I really want to hear you unpack
this
sometimes Rick someone says to me you
know when you do stand up and you're
hosting don't hand them the mic put it
in the stand and I'm like [__] thank
you this is rested Pete this is Pete who
had a meal recently right this is Pete
who's having his emotional and
psychological needs met this is Pete
that probably has something on the
calendar that he's looking forward to
this is Pete that it was probably a
sunny day I can be affected by the
weather it sounds like it's a great so
great it's best case I love this Pete
yeah I love all the pizza but sometimes
it's rainy Pete maybe Pete missed dinner
maybe Pete didn't have any caffeine
maybe Pete had a bad set five hours of
sleep five hours of sleep baby got up
and I'm not having my psychological or
emotional needs met and the same person
says the same thing hey when you're
hosting you might want to put that mic
in the stand instead of handing it to
them it's just a preference uh I might
and I'm not proud of this in fact I'm
gonna say this is one of my least
favorite things about myself the
irregularity of my response but
sometimes if it's that peep rainy day
hungry Pete I'll I will hold Vendetta
against that person for the remainder of
their days like it's not I I hate you
don't recognize that
that this was rainy day stubbed my toe
Pete I might even but it's still got
into it's almost like it's stored in fat
and it gets stuck in there or mud
because it's called soluble uh uh uh uh
uh
criticism soluble yeah what do you mean
um
like it's uh emulsified into like it got
into your fat right usually it's
deflected by these other things these
these benefit of the doubt programs that
I have running these kindness programs
and when I'm not at my best the Harpoon
goes all the way in and sticks in my fat
or my whatever and then I can't get it
out even though I'm aware that I'm being
completely irrational and unfair but
I'll see somebody and go that's the
person that told me that shirt I have
sucks or whatever or maybe something
more kind I have a I have a tool to help
you with that tell me the tool
um even when it's it's
eight hours of sleep Pete uh and you're
able to receive it the way you saw it is
you could deflect those things it
doesn't affect you yes
um but even that means that there's
something to deflect yes I have found
and when I say this this isn't like me
being so enlightened it's just a tool
that I have when I could use it you're
in a safe space this is a spinach in
Your Teeth podcast
uh
the tool yeah you know I was just
thinking about how this opened up with
me wanting to check Amir
which is funny that you busted my balls
on that just a tiny bit a tiny bit you
busted my balls where you think it's
okay to tell me I have spinach in my
teeth but you didn't want me to see if I
had spinach in my teeth myself
truly and literally
and I think that is actually
you're a horrible person no no that's
hilarious um but also I was looking at
you as a human mirror to use your
parlance but I didn't need to see me
through your eyes
but I am a mirror
we all are
[__] a
so part of my confidence in teasing your
desire to look at a mirror other than I
was doing just a metaphor I liked it
prove it say it backwards
metaphor was I doing yeah no not quite
doing I
I know was I forget it yeah headed back
in twice yeah we'll have to listen to it
twice
um I would have told you that's you see
what I'm saying like you were like why
didn't you let me look in the mirror I
was this is hilarious so we're still on
this tell me the tool
um
uh
uh I have found that by valuing
information so much it kind of
supersedes the ego and I talked about an
example this example on my podcast once
before I always have to say that I get
insecure when I repeat but uh here is a
uh an example and a microcosm for how it
could be anywhere I was on out with
somebody and we were going in some place
and I was in high energy bit mode
TBM and we walked in and she says she
goes
you're so loud
yeah and I was you know uh sunny day
Pete yes uh and this is when I clocked
that I'm oh you could do this more than
just here this is maybe accidental here
because when she said it I went oh thank
you
um
I didn't think I was loud but I know she
thought I was loud so other people may
have thought it was loud it wasn't about
me
it was about her feeling I was loud I'm
so glad she told me because imagine she
didn't tell me and now I'm just the loud
guy who she resents worse she tells
someone else that's the the next worst
thing you do is go like I mean that's
kind of how I got kicked out of this
basketball thing which I will tell about
later but if these people told me how
they felt I would have at least had the
choice to change my behavior and if I
didn't I didn't but I at least now have
the awareness right Mike in the mic
stand
um and uh
so I realized oh when somebody tells me
something instead of really that being
about who I am which it might be and I
might still also see it that way but
just like hear the thing like what's the
information being told I completely
agree I I think you're right on the
money yeah we've doing your podcast a
couple times you know I'm a spiritual
person completely agree and think what
I'm saying sunny day Pete or rainy day
Pete what I really mean is like
right-minded Pete wrong-minded but even
wrong-minded Pete recognizes oh this is
just data that's true I'm with you
there's a potential for wrong-minded not
getting his needs met Pete to still be
right-minded you know what I'm saying
yeah like you can transcend it in fact
that's what spirituality has a lot to do
with that like even though nothing is
going my way I'm going to be mindful and
stop and check myself before I wreck
myself that's really what it is stopping
myself before I wreck myself it rhymes
stop and choosing have you said that
before I also like big butts and I
cannot lie these are just things I say
you should write these down I would but
I love it when there's a beat and I say
them really quickly okay here's here's
why I think you're correct to stick the
landing on the compliment
Richard Rohr says your true self like
your ego list self meaning you're just
your pure awareness can't be offended
and really it's because it sees the
impartiality and sort of almost the
absurdity of of reality and someone's
just telling you something and you don't
have to attach this story to it I'm loud
I'm embarrassed she's wrong [__] her
what does she just say she's the Arbiter
of volume now you just go like so it's
okay I'm having you could put it this
way I'm having a dream where there's a
person who has more impression I'm
having a dream
did you dress up for Martin Luther King
Day
what do you mean for Martin Luther King
Day do you dress up help me with this
rope okay
um you dress up every year uh so
um does that make sense yes did I hear
you right your quote makes me also think
of that Eleanor Roosevelt quote you know
the one I'm talking about no one can
make you fear and feel inferior without
your consent I was gonna say do you guys
know where the bathroom is
she mugging to the camera she used to
say that all the time is that the quote
you meant yeah love that quote yeah and
that's that's exactly what I mean and
often just say yes and your Prem
I promise oh imagine wait a minute you
are so fun
funny
just fun too funny is funny is part of
fun but yeah it's always part of funny
fun is one and then funny
it's two
that's kind of funny that like when
you're being funny you can't be funny
enough person that's creating fun yeah
that's yeah you can be funny without fun
sometimes it's me I was re-watching The
Sopranos for the for the yeah and uh I'm
laughing out loud at things there's no
jokes yeah it's actually a serious
situation yeah it's just funny it's like
why is this funny it's funny because
it's so real yeah
it's not a fun situation he's about to
chop somebody's balls off for not giving
a percentage of his hotel to the the the
wife's father or whatever Jew guy Jewish
try not to talk about other people but
it's a character in a show it's the
Hasidic Jewish man and they're going to
cut off and it's so funny because it's
just children one it's just so funny I
agree I'm having a fun time watching it
it doesn't mean the scene is fun I
understand but funny provides fun I
think 10 out of 10 times I agree at
least at least a brief moment I actually
love that scene because there's like an
envy that this the the Hasidic Jewish
man has a value system right that
transcends even his physical body and
you can if I'm remembering the scene
correctly there's like this weird
respect yeah that they have yeah he's
like if we don't kill this guy we should
have him work for us exactly because but
you see that yearning you can be a
master of money and capitalism and
success are you talking about Jews no no
no I'm talking about the mafia okay good
save
but if you see if you encounter a Godly
person a person that has some sort of
connection to something eternal then
then you wreck like in those moments you
can go [__] I have all the money and I
literally have all the power but this
person is actually richer than I am
that's what I remember from that scene
does that make sense we'll be right back
after a word from Squarespace
okay we can do the minerals
we'll be right back but it's not
Squarespace but if you do have to look
I'm not being paid to say this but if
you have to make a website so I use
Squarespace yeah it seems to be pretty
good great
yeah speaking of my front dump style my
website get the [__] out of here I gotta
Squarespace that [__] yeah so
squarespace.com take your shoes off I
don't have them as a sponsor either oh
okay we'll just go to Squarespace just
because it's a it's a resource replug
yeah it's this is a free plug for you um
but real quick we'll cut to our sponsor
Marshall Ray gallery
if you're looking for just the right
flooring you need choices and at
Marshall Carpet One you'll find
thousands of choices
[Music]
including carpet
Hardwood
rugs
and luxury vinyl
so make the right choice and visit
Marshall Carpet One and rug gallery
and we promise with more than 50 years
as a family-owned business
we've got you covered
[Music]
what's happening weirdos this episode is
brought To Us by our friends at ritual
multivitamins you can talk fantasy
football with your friends all day but
asking them for health advice you know
it's not the move ritual takes the
guesswork out of the vitamin game their
multivitamin for men is based on science
to help fill common nutrient gaps in the
diet and level up your nutrient goals it
is an all-around win as a mostly vegan
I'm not a great vegan but I'm I eat a
lot of vegan food there are gaps in my
diet and since I've been taking ritual
vitamins it's great to go to the doctor
and get a clean bill of vitamin Health
they check my levels and they tell me I
am killing it which means these gaps
they be they be getting filled in
they're filled in they'd be getting
filled it they're filled in this is what
I'm saying it is an incredible easy way
to get the nutrition and the vitamins
that I need also they're Pro pre and
postbiotics that I take in their
symbiotic plus every morning I also do
intermittent fasting and it's sometimes
tricky to take especially certain
vitamins on and stomach ritual doesn't
work that way there's a delayed release
which means these vitamins aren't going
to just be peed out of your system they
wait to be broken down until they're in
your intestines and your lower
intestines which is where they can
actually be absorbed and get into your
blood which is what you want so these
are scientifically developed
multivitamins with high quality key
ingredients in clean bioavailable forms
ritual is a new type of two ritual is
your new type of two a days from helping
support heart health with omega-3 DHA to
normal muscle function and normal immune
function with vitamin D3 this is a small
step you can take to have a major impact
and it's traceable
because uh where your nutrients come
from is just as important as what
they're for it's very interesting they
come with the literature so you can find
where they're sourcing these things it's
vegan friendly non-GMO sugar-free
gluten-free major allergen uh allergen
free and their capsule has a delayed
release that I mentioned and a minty
Essence in every bottle to keep things
fresh and helps make taking your
multivitamin every day actually
enjoyable essential for men is a quality
multivitamin from a company you can
actually trust and get this ritual is
offering my listeners 10 off during your
first three months Go to rituals.com
weird to start ritual or add essential
for men to your subscription today or
the symbiotic Plus for your gut health
these guys have you covered show your
support the show show some support to
your body and to your gut Go to
ritual.com
weird for 10 off during your first three
months we're also brought To Us by our
our friends at Rocket money try it free
for 30 days it's enough time to try and
completely forget about a subscription
or a service how many times have we fall
in for that try this streamer free for
30 days you subscribe you watch one show
you forget that you signed up for it and
now you have a recurring thing before
you know it you're paying for a
subscription you don't use every single
month what a drag with rocket money you
can change that with a few quick Taps do
you know how much your subscriptions
cost most Americans think they spend
about 80 bucks a month on subscriptions
when the actual cost is closer to 200 if
you don't know exactly how much you're
spending a month you need rocket money
the average person has around 12 paid
subscriptions think about that
12. if you think you're only subscribed
to a handful of services you might want
to double check and with rocket money
you can quickly identify and cancel all
of your unwanted subscriptions rocket
money formerly known as true bill is a
personal finance app that finds and
cancels your unwanted subscriptions
monitors your spending and helps lower
your bills all in one place over 80
percent of people have subscriptions
they forget about like that streaming or
service that you watch one show and you
never use like I mentioned rocket money
will quickly and easily identify your
subscriptions for you so you can stop
paying for the ones you don't want
simply find the subscriptions you don't
want press cancel and Rocket money will
do it for you no more long hold times
with customer service or tedious
emailing back and forth rocket money
makes canceling subscriptions as easy as
a click of a button over three million
people have used rocket money saving the
average person up to seven whoa 720 a
year so it couldn't be easier I myself
had more more sleeper subscriptions than
I care to admit and Rocket money just
like they say one click boom finds them
and cancels them for you you don't have
to go through all the like are you sure
you want to cancel here's a special deal
you want this people trying to keep you
on the hook it does it for you they find
them they cancel them and it saves you a
ton of money so stop throwing your cash
away cancel unwanted un cancel unwanted
subscriptions and manage your expenses
the easy way by going to
rocketmoney.com weird that's
rocketmoney.com weird one last time
let's clean up the financial game save
some bread
rocketmoney.com slash weird and show
your support of this show last but not
least
guys vessi shoes what a wonderful
product a
waterproof guys water roof not water
resistant the vessi shoe is an
incredible
game changing shoe that is slip on keeps
water out keeps socks dry looks amazing
perfect for hikes perfect for every day
I don't know if you guys know but it was
raining for about three months in
California we were desperate for rain
and then we got more than we could
handle it was muddy it was wet it was
nasty and I was so glad that I had my
vessi shoes to keep my socks from
getting soggy cold and gross and into my
feet these are slip-on and amazing 100
waterproof not water resistant
waterproof and warm shoes that are
lighter and more comfortable than boots
they have a lug a rugged rubber outsole
that gives you extra grip in wet
conditions so you're not going to be
slipping around on rocks or in your
driveway added lining inside for extra
warmth in the cold and as I said they
slip on and off it's not like lacing on
a super serious intense boot it is an
easy slip on and off quick and easy to
get outside made from dime attacks a
super soft knit material that keeps your
feet warm in the cold but cool in the
warmer months it doesn't feel like it
should be waterproof but it is and it is
comfortable and it is dry it is a huge
step forward step forward in shoe
technology like shoe boot hybrid more
like a shoe protects you like a boot I
absolutely love it keeps me from fearing
the the outdoors from fearing getting
that soggy sock from getting that wet
toe all of that nasty coldness and
wetness that you just want to keep out
the first time I threw on my vessies I
thought they looked like amazing
designer shoes because the diamondtex
actually looks like a cool pattern so
they're very stylish they're very
comfortable and they keep you comfy in a
rainy climate and they keep you warm and
dry in wet and cold months and they also
breathe in the warmer mode so these are
like a year-round thing Bessie has lots
of styles to choose from vesies are my
go-to shoes by my door check them out in
the link vesi.com weird for your pair of
Bessie shoes you will get 15 off
click bessie.com weird and use promo
code weird for 15 off your entire order
thanks again vessi use promo code weird
for 15 off your entire order and show
your support of the show they've saved
my feed from wet soggy socks so give it
a try all right everybody let's get back
to our friend Rick Glassman
and we're back it says it on his hat
yeah
that's a magic mine that's my favorite
it has new atropics and adaptogens and a
little bit of caffeine in it but I love
it if you want to drink it for your
second half
give it a shaky poo if you drink it
matcha lion's mane adaptogens
and nootropics very good very little
caffeine I don't see Lions man in here
if I see the other things lion's mane is
what it means by
um nootropics it's one of the
neurotropics that's in it give it a
shake
now give it a check in one in one in one
have I showed you my impression of a guy
who's really nervous to try new things
but he doesn't want other people to see
yeah he's nervous that's it um asked me
if I've ever had this before have you
ever had that before no it's fine
foreign
now that we're back
you vomit I'm fine bad
is a lot of fun
let's do a fake up you also do fake UPS
fake That's What I Call pretending
you're just waking up in a movie or film
my wake up acting how do you know that
you do that you call it wake up acting I
call it fake up oh you've seen you've
seen this in something we both do it
oh yeah great I didn't know that yeah I
do it we're both silly beans and we're
both obsessed with people in movies I
don't do it silly I don't know if you
know this but at this point I am an
award-winning dramatic actor as we see
it on Amazon Prime but I I wake up I do
drama wake up acting not silly oh no
what's silly is to do it no no no no
you need to understand
playing the game of doing a very
realistic dramatic wake up that's what's
silly not the wake up itself not when
you do it dramatically
I know what you're saying you don't know
what I'm saying and that's the
difference no I don't think you know
what I know you're saying you're saying
the fact that that is even something
that you're doing yeah the drama of it
no drama like a drama class like the the
acting the The Dramatics I'm saying
no
I don't mean drama as in sad I mean I
mean uh like acting performing to
perform it what I'm saying is in the
same way that it's silly to be like I'm
gonna do a guy that's nervous to try new
things that's kind of funny can I show
you what I mean for an example and how
unsilly this is yeah but I don't I
should watch it and then tell me I'm
wrong but Rick I don't think the wake up
itself is silly this is why even the
situation of me doing it when you watch
okay do it okay can you just give me the
benefit of the doubt all right I still
don't think you understand I don't think
you understand go ahead you're about to
do a very serious fake up and when we'll
see fake up is silly because by Design
it's fake what
what is happening
to come by a huge yawn what I'm saying
is it's not when it's not fake and
you're in a situation yeah or you're
tired and you fall asleep and you wake
up
so I want to show you how serious it is
okay wait it's already begun
a little wink
let me show you how serious this is okay
will you do me a favor yeah will you
close your eyes sure you fall asleep but
don't peek I'm I'm also you're asleep
and you're gonna wake up before me I'll
tell you when to wake up okay
I'm not gonna peek
and I'm gonna say call your name and you
just don't answer to your sleep okay
namaste
hey
you could wake up in 10 seconds I'm not
gonna tell you wake up in 10 seconds
Pete
I'm sorry sorry I forgot about your sock
roll I was so happy I will show you how
serious this is I was so happy I'm sorry
about the song let me show you how
serious this is that was just too good
hold on let me show you how serious this
is
uh you're awake now try to wake me up
okay I'm awake
wreck
wreck yeah
Rick
you're on a podcast man wake up
so it's very good
oh [__] I'm so tired
what's up it's buried isn't it now you
know what I mean the whole time I just
wanted to say to you it's not silly and
you're like yes it is okay I wanted to
do this you know and I'm like Pete just
let me do my [__] bit I loved it and
I did not know that's right that's
because I explained it like a dramatic
award-winning actor yeah that was very
good the trick is when you have
double-sided sticky tape to do two
layers so when you're done with it the
first time
you could peel it off and then you have
another one
ready yeah
I love that shout out to Taryn kill him
by the way because I used to buy new
mustaches constantly and he told me
about double-sided sticky tape or toupee
tape if you are a redneck or you might
be a redneck if you don't you anyway uh
you stupid and uh and now I just I get
to reuse my mustaches all the time I
love that and I need it yeah well you
must
what do you mean
listen here's one for you because Val
and I do these all the time we do fake
UPS I know you do them dramatically are
you going to do another one are you
really tired
you're doing gum acting
you're pretending you have a piece of
gum
you don't have gum because I I've been
watching you and you don't have it but
it looks very much like you have gum can
I do it too yeah but with gum chew with
gum chewing acting you also have gum gum
confidence
oh yeah
one time I did a stand-up set at comics
in New York and I played the video back
and I was so confident I was fake
chewing gum like that's not a bit go to
a clip I don't have it
but
oh you're gonna blow a little
here's a new one for you yeah
Val and I do acting games all the time
love it here's the here's the scene
uh you can do it with your coffee or
your water whatever you want coffee
okay yeah
here's the scene can I hold your coffee
can I hand you that coffee okay
here's the scene you're at a party nice
you've been drinking a lot lately like
alcohol alcohol and you're dating a
woman what's her name uh in the scene
doesn't matter I'm just including you
okay Jessica Jessica now Jessica asked
yes Jess yeah you call her Jess but it's
Jessica yeah so you and Jess are at this
party and she's standing next what does
she look like she looks exactly like
Jennifer Garner let's just call her Jen
okay let it be Jennifer Garner
I'm at a party with Jennifer Garner's
birthday by the way that's right April
21st why do you know that I know
everybody's birthday what is mine I
forgot
okay you're at a birthday
party for Jennifer Garner on April 21st
oh I'm dating her too so it's her
birthday party yeah so we're at it's
like I I helped with this one she loves
you
I've been waiting like it's going great
she was one of my big celebrity crushes
good choice yeah
she loves you she's so pretty and
talented and she seems so nice she just
wishes you would cool it on the drinking
yeah but I mean I can handle myself it's
fine I'm choosing to do this I could
stop whenever I want it's a little much
it's a party
that's great that's great that was great
but you promised her for her birthday
that you wouldn't drink I I said I
wouldn't get drunk no no no fine
I'll tell you why it's important because
I'm hiding alcohol in the drink no okay
I'm already I'm having so much fun I
know you're gonna love it
acting games are the best and everyone
should play how fortunate are we that we
get to do it for a living that's what
I'm saying it should be a silly being
activity for everybody
loved that one lto
love that
p a
pa uh I was just making it very good
thank you here's what happens okay at
the top of the scene
people that don't know it's a beginning
the beginning of the scene people don't
know
hide the straw
that was P PBB
um you can give us one piece of dialogue
not important just something to
establish you're in the middle of a
story I am the host of the party my name
is Jared yo you're hosting Jennifer's
birthday party yes okay because you guys
are getting some work done
on your house oh so you didn't want to
have at your house you had a Jared's
house right not Jared Fogle I know okay
but it's not that one
it is
how did I get there did I take the train
you took this Subway
okay
um me non-jared Fogle you say one line
when I say action say one line that
establishes that we're at this party
doesn't matter sure but the way you say
it doesn't matter I know you're trying
to make it low stakes but you're taking
away the fun for me I just want you to
know that I appreciate you say it
matters you know it matters thank you
for sharing it didn't matter let's not
do it spinach in the teeth
I hand you a drink you ordered a tonic
water right I'm handing you a strong gin
and tonic right so I haven't drank
anything yet you haven't you've been
strong cured in fact you're still true
to your word you asked me to get you a
tonic right and when I take a sip is
when I realize when you take a sip you
realize it's a strong it's like a
quadruple gin and tonic yeah and you
want that gin and tonic so I'm like I
just like to see your choice when you
sip it not too close
okay
when you sip it I want to see a little
realization that a wicked accident has
happened in your favor
and then I'd like to see the second sip
be the choice you are going to keep it
yeah understood because it's just too
good it fell in your lap of course and
you can handle one Jen's not gonna know
all right and I'm fine and I can stop
whenever I want that's right all right
are you ready yeah
action
it's six or seven at least but it's uh
it's fun to be there but it doesn't
matter
hey there
thanks for setting this up for us by the
way
you're welcome yeah they call it divorce
dust when you're getting Renovations
done so it's important to
have some time
really loving that seconds I loved that
choice you are an award-winning dramatic
actor can I give a little advice to
people
um for acting can't wait this is gonna
sound really corny hit it all your only
job as an actor you have two jobs
outside of being a professional showing
up on time Etc you have two jobs as an
actor to be fantastic go ahead in order
ask Stanley Kubrick on this one
who know your [__] Lines no your
lines know your lines know them not have
an idea not know them pretty well know
your lines entirely so you don't have to
think about what I'm gonna say next got
it because when you're not just like in
life when you're not in here you're
present you have to be present and that
brings us to number two
have the thoughts
have the thought don't think about what
it's like to hide sip hide the Sip
right don't make a choice just be there
be there yeah and that's a great that's
why it's like well Rick how are you such
a good actor why are you so good at
playing all these different roles why
are you so engaging and do people say
that yes honestly they really do I'm
just yeah all the time I'm just having
fun yeah I get it I think you're
hilarious funny it's really funny what
you do
tell if you hate me now really no but I
you know what that really was
I know you didn't mean that and then I'm
like do they know pointing to the
microphone
well here's an interesting here's an
interesting extension of this idea of
being present
um
which I know you subscribe to very very
much but this is just my version of it
it helps you also realize how much is
out of your control yes because you're
just here doing the thing
having the thoughts being there if they
don't get it that doesn't affect you but
you know what does thinking about it
right you can't control what other
people think even if you try you're not
going to know if you're doing the right
you're doing it right
right get rid of it because that's a
good thought to question if I behave a
certain way I can control how people
feel is that true can I shine a
magnifying on glass on that because this
was a this was a discovery of mine that
like I I have a visceral uh connection
to yes yeah yes I thought you're gonna
say no I have nothing to say
I don't know where to go now you are
great um so first I want to just close
the the acting and the people do say the
things stuff all the time I'm not
surprised
I was just telling you how great you are
um did I get you right under the eye
yeah the one part of you that was
protected by glasses
um but I was being playful I was playing
arrogant I was just joking and I'm gonna
transition into something real so I want
to like yes say now
as your lawyer yes go on
so
I came into some self-awareness six
years ago with an Autism diagnosis for
you
somebody else
uh for me
um and when I got that diagnosis I was
very excited
oh that makes sense I was learning about
things
all these unrelated issues that now
there was a through line too
uh I became a more aware of some of the
things I lacked awareness in I was able
to receive certain things differently
because like oh maybe even though I
don't see it that way that is true
and
that's a good one do you remember an
example of that
um just because well I mean there's just
the the the her saying you're being
really loud yeah
um
uh when um
when uh anyone tells me anything I used
to I used to feel
um you'd name drop Maya Angelou what's
her name you know people never remember
what you say or do they just remember
how many numbers you get
so
um I'm gonna do a little name drop here
uh I had Bill Burr on my podcast
that's easy to go at SNL
wait didn't you write for Sno no did you
submit a package oh yeah
I used to walk it into 30 Rock and drop
it to some guy that worked the elevator
and it's like yeah I'll throw this out
for you
you really gave it to somebody there who
doesn't you said will you give this to
somebody to Lauren Michaels you'd get to
reception and you'd hand it off do you
know Lauren Michaels have you met him no
he walked by me once what'd he say
that's the point he said nothing and I
had just performed on Fallon and he just
walked right by and then mullaney dear
mullaney goes like Pete it's like when
you do a stand-up show do you compliment
every stand-up that you saw in the show
that's what it's like for him to walk
through
well you're nicer than Lauren Michaels
when I oh if I ever opened a show I said
that you have to be fair I've heard you
say that actually a perfectly told me
ladies and gentlemen what do people say
about Rick behind his back that he's
nicer than Lauren Michael
um all right NPR I used to uh when I
would open a show and I was first I
would uh give it up for all the comics
you've seen so far very good
um so uh I I said this what I'm about to
tell you to Bill and Bill's like I'll
say the thing first
um I used to think that whatever I'm
thinking you're thinking I didn't
recognize that the person opposite me
thought differently than me and he was
talking about like yeah that's what
being a comic is feel like realizing
like it's so weird that people think see
it differently yeah like how weird that
you don't understand this perspective
and it's our job to like explain it in a
funny way yeah um but I'm like I'm like
no no it's not that I find it odd that
you have a different perspective I know
that you're thinking what I'm thinking
without having the understanding that
maybe you're not
whatever I'm thinking that was the kind
of the um
kind of like the uh not the inciting
incident but like the the
just the subtext of the character that I
am phenomenal thing I was talking to you
about which was I I'm the best
basketball player in this game I'm the
best I'm funny because I am people like
playing with me I'm the first pick
because we win and I'm the guy and then
I found out not only do it might not
pick first people don't even want to
play when I'm there
that wasn't a possibility I'm the best
right and it's not always such an
arrogant thing it could be like ice I'm
ugly I suck so everyone thinks I suck
can I just interject what a uh I was
gonna say nightmare but what a challenge
it's a challenging thing to have your
world view which is I'm phenomenal
Everyone likes me I'm the best be
flipped on its head yeah that must have
been hard you know a tangible obstacle
that I have in stand up even though I'm
more aware is still something that is
difficult for me to know how I'm being
received which is
you do a joke and people laugh ooh this
is working they don't either drop it or
change it I still have no idea if I
think it's funny and they don't laugh
they're wrong and or I have to do
something a little different but it is
funny yeah and if they laugh and I don't
think it's funny I don't even if you
were to say how was your set I will
never know I could only tell you how I
felt about it I have no idea I have no
idea yeah
um and I know a lot of people aren't
sure so this isn't exclusive to me but I
mean I have no I have almost no data to
this stuff and it has gotten in the way
of stand up when I'm trying to build an
act where it's like I I
I don't know is there a a strange
superpower to it as well I mean it
sounds like you could be pretty Fearless
then yeah the superpower is that uh
people have said uh I did a podcast with
John radnitski do you know John 250k
right no it hasn't come out yet okay um
do you know who John radnitsky is a
comedian John Krasinski yeah John
rudnisky shout out to John great guy it
was that to Krasinski or Redmond shout
out yeah that was a John rutnitz okay
would you give one to Krasinski because
he's I've been every time I go like this
did he do it like that I think so
yeah okay
the old I don't know if the office would
have been a hit if every 35 seconds John
Krasinski was going can I tell you
something disagree
can I tell you something no
the fact that you said can I tell you
something made that disagree so much
funnier and that's the superpower it was
a bull it was a bowl to put a banana in
and now I'm laughing that there's one
understand that you didn't say orange
okay
or I would have rather you said orange I
think would be that joke aren't you glad
I didn't say banana so he this is a
person who thinks I would prefer you to
say orange I I just also want you to
know that I have some of what you're
saying there's a Ralph Waldo Emerson
Ralph Waldo
where Ralph Waldo
Ralph Waldo get in here where is he stop
being a transcendentalist Ralph Waldo
and come in for supper Ralph Waldo well
I can never find him his name is Ralph
Waldo is the impetus for that bit he
says to believe that what you believe is
right for you is right for everybody is
genius
interesting you know the opposite I love
a quote from Mark Twain which is uh guys
I'm hungry you want to get something to
eat
he didn't say that often two or three
times a month
um did you see what I'm saying there's
like a good side to thinking because I
can get that I'm like I get it yeah I'm
synced up and I understand and I can be
the representative of how we're all
thinking but that's very close to
delusion it is delusion it is delusion
but the the delusional aspect of it is
to believe that I'm right and here's
what everybody's thinking what I was
missing and though I still I'm now aware
that that's not the case what I was
missing was
I didn't know I was doing that yeah I
wasn't choosing to be right consciously
it was we're all here we all what you
you see it also the idea that I know
something so you must know it a great
example of that which is Justin's joke
structure form would be me
deconstructing jokes that make sense
because I know the origins of the joke
but if you don't know the boy or my arms
tired joke yeah it doesn't make sense
when you do it I completely understand
Rory Scoville is maybe my favorite
comedian I love him to death and I I
feel like we're similar I'm going for
something similar that Rory is going for
and when I watch him it's very
informative to me because I'll watch
Rory do something and that makes me
realize that I'm doing it and he doesn't
do it a lot like this yeah the safe and
the robe it's very much like the safe in
the row because I'll see Rory this is a
bad example but he'll go like what's
that give a good one
yeah but this is a fake example is what
I mean it's a very good example but it's
not real because I don't want you to
think Rory is a doofus he'll say
something you think he's fantastic he
said that in a text to me
Rory
kaczynski's two krasinski's will be
right back searching for a bet Rory will
say let's say he's doing a bit about
hats it's like why is it called a hat
it's a hat because it hats on your path
but he says it like that and I I've seen
him do the bit and I'm like he's not
supposed to say hats on his bath it's
supposed to be like it's like a shirt on
your back but he said hats on the bat
but he doesn't realize that and then
he'll go like where are you guys why
didn't you laugh maybe if I do it again
and he'll do it again but then they'll
say it right and they laugh I'm like I
do that that's also a type of delusion
I'm on stage thinking that the audience
is so with me that I can actually remove
70 of the words and they'll still
understand me yeah but I wouldn't change
my brain for the world but my uh Val
will say after show she's like remember
they don't know what you're talking
about yeah it's like it's like removing
the First Act of a movie yeah like maybe
they could still figure stuff out but
you didn't you have to establish certain
things right right now with structure
and with jokes that makes sense and you
could take swings and you're in the
pocket you're being funny and a lot of
what you do and I do as well but is just
kind of uh uh what's what I'm looking
for like not word association but like
free yeah free association free
associate free associating right
associating so you're just kind of like
that's in play mode
um but when it's in personal life and
you don't recognize that you're doing
that and then you're doing this to
people who don't say you have spinach in
your teeth now we're years into this
relationship and we have been calibrated
completely differently yeah and they
think Rick is blah blah blah which he is
and I think this is great everything's
great everything's perfect
and the I am phenomenal thing
was just that I am phenomenal and then I
found out on that how did you find out
the letter
yeah from Bill yeah beautiful letter did
It win an Emmy uh the letter no one of
the few things he wrote that hasn't was
it nominated so what
walk me through it even though you've
said it before I haven't heard it before
um sure but I would also like to the
point of me bringing this up that I want
to at least tie into effect was the um
the idea of uh uh of um
I don't remember what God is there but
remember what it was so I'm just going
to continue on with that thing please um
I got this autism diagnosis yeah uh and
yes and I'm like uh awesome I was I was
excited
um uh I told my friends about it I
talked about it on stage and then
um I was uh some even friends some
people were like yeah obviously we've
known that and some people like no you
don't that's not what autism is
I would talk about on stage and I found
that like when people would would be
like oh I like this I connected to this
you remind me of my son it was usually
that it was usually women telling me I
reminded them of their son
um when I say usually I mean a fair
amount of shows there was a there's a
woman in the audience who was an
autistic son that they were aware of
and then there were some people that's
like that's not what autism is
and I found myself at first
explaining myself well you didn't know
what I was like when I was a kid before
I before I developed some of these tools
that I have and that and then I felt
like I'm selling them on on this thing
that I didn't feel was an identity but
then like am I why am I and I felt
really bad about it so much so that I'm
like I just don't want to talk about it
I don't want to tell people it doesn't
it's none of their business for better
or worse it's just it's a thing I'm
still learning about
um with that I got so depressed
I remember what it was about it was
about uh not being able to control how
other people receive you
so I lived 30 years of my life knowing
that I'm the best I've recently started
talking about on stage how um I only
recently found out I had no friends as a
kid I had no idea I wasn't excluded I
wasn't bullied I just thought everyone
was busy I had no idea I had no friends
because up here because yeah David he
can't come over today or tomorrow or the
day after I talk about this on stage
where I had I once asked my mom to talk
to his mom because he said his mom said
he's not allowed and my mom had to not
tell me probably it does he just thinks
he wrestled too much I you know I didn't
know so I I wrongly wrongly felt
everybody feels about me positively
which was great for my self-worth I I
love myself I'm fun I'm funny
I'm phenomenal
and then I found out I'm not and by that
I mean I became aware that oh there's a
possibility that people think
differently than me not that they think
differently to me I disagreed there's a
possibility
because if you didn't tell me I have
spinach in my teeth I don't
I don't right right
so then I got really depressed and I and
I I tried to is this okay I'm talking a
lot
love it I was going to tell Katie make a
note because this is good for our cold
open great
um that was we'll tell her I just did oh
it's hard for them to find Cold opens
um
go on
I'm trying to now like figure out okay
how could I be better right and there
are ways to be better but like that's
the mission now
um
and I would I started doing things like
what I just did to you but I did a lot
more is this okay yeah is that one of
your tools that's one of them to check
in because you might not tell me it's
not okay so I'm like kind of giving you
the opportunity to be like I could take
it right I do that
um I would preempt I just want to let
you know that sometimes I get a little
annoying
uh sometimes and if you're not in the
mood I I'm totally fine just you could
tell me right um uh I talk about on
stage now where I learned only six years
ago when somebody says how you doing I
could just say good things how are you
it doesn't matter how I'm doing you just
say that right there are things that you
just so I was really just going I'm over
here and you go yeah I'm over here yeah
you want to get something to eat I'm
good how are you good it doesn't matter
you know what it also is it's just an
opportunity to scan their vocal pattern
for tension for safety you know what I
mean how are you ah
I'm okay you're like maybe I'm gonna
walk keep walking I don't even think it
maybe I don't I believe you I don't
subscribe to that I think it's a
subconscious thing that we picked up on
because that's what people do to us
people say how you doing so you say how
you doing
yeah but I think it's a way of going
like how's how's the sound coming out of
you today okay I believe you
I had a a somebody that goes uh uh he
goes how you doing I said good uh he
said good things how are you I said uh
oh no I said how you doing he said good
how are you
how does it work say how you doing I
want to see something how you doing I'm
good how are you I'm good
then he said how are you how are you
and I'm like I just did this but I'm
like I'm good
yeah that happens every once and then we
walk into a room and he goes how you
been man and I just went uh you just
yeah look can I just say people with
Autism are totally right
you know what I'm saying yeah what what
autism is is it's it's a in my
experience and there are people in my
family that have it and I think I might
have a Sprinkle of it I'm not sure but
like what it is is a lessened ability to
damp down all of the nonsense most of us
are overlooking do you understand
like yeah that's a weird attribute of it
yeah that's I'm not saying it's all of
it I'm just saying what it is is like
paranoia is similar too it's like
paranoid people are right like there
could be an earthquake there and a plane
engine could fall we can have an
aneurysm that's all right focusing on it
it's just like developing tools to not
let it own your life similar to autism
it's like it's weird that people say how
are you but they don't really care more
specifically than weird it's like what
is the purpose of this where is the
logic in this are we trying to connect
if that's the case let's connect but
that's not connecting by the way that's
why I really I can't diagnose myself but
that's why I relate yeah to the autistic
perspective as I'm it's also very funny
like the autistic perspective is often
very funny because it's very literal and
it's and it's looking for meaning and
it's looking for reason in a world that
very often has little of either of those
things and pointing that out is often
very funny yeah but a lot of people and
fun are just go
a lot of people are just going around
eating ice cream you know what I'm
saying and that's fine which by the way
could raise your cholesterol because of
saturated fats which I believe are like
something about the way that fats are
chained up yeah I don't know enough
about it I don't know either but it
makes it coating around your arteries
and that's gross and it sucks man yuck
um can I just say heart attack yuck
gross yeah it's gross yeah you have to
you have to you have to be conscious of
what what you're doing and you're eating
and having Advocates around to not judge
you but bring awareness to if you have
something into your teeth or what you
might be putting into your teeth yeah is
just like or your artists just
information that you could you could
take and make a decision with
I'll ignore it I'll disregard it or oh
good good call I look at it as someone's
helping you cheat at a test that's life
I'm I've said this many times on this
pod there's my little disclaimer I'm a
help me help me like I I receive it as
love 99 of the time there is the one
percent wrong-minded Pete that will be
like [__] this guy I don't know why it
just comes in wrong every once in a
while but most of the time if you have a
tip I remember where I was when Camille
was like stop wearing white socks you
look like you just got out of a soccer
game and I was like all right huh I wear
white socks maybe they're back but this
was in 2000. yeah three right and that's
when we're pre-covered pre-covered which
is what changed the algorithm right
Maya Angelou married uh Paul Thomas
Anderson did you know that just if we're
dumping out our callback grips I didn't
know that yeah hot ref mod apatel yeah I
remember that
frog what are your other tips
um because he because I feel like
autistic tips are good tips for
everybody I still didn't land that oh
okay
um but I could get to it quicker I'm
waving you in so uh I'm looking to find
new stuff I'm I'm asking people
questions
um um paying more attention to the fact
that what I'm thinking may exist but
that's I might be the only one taking
this yeah
this is going great I'm saying that kind
of stuff okay I just didn't know for a
little bit I'm letting you know it's
going well yeah
um but like
seeking so much information and
exhausting everybody involved and
I realized that I I still don't know for
two reasons one it's it's I haven't
found a pattern of it all and two I
don't believe that a you'll tell me your
truth and B you even know what you're
feeling and why you might be Brady day
Pete and you're triggered
people are so not
oftentimes people are shown not in touch
with their feelings yes that not only do
they not know they don't know what
they're feeling let alone feeling safe
and comfortable enough to express it to
someone when they don't want people to
tell them things thought ripped right
out of my brain so now I'm like
I have no idea so I I realized something
before everything when I had felt so
great about myself and high self-worth
and I am phenomenal and I know this is
probably assumed but I want to make sure
I say this was me feeling this way not
defining myself as this thing I just
feel great about myself now I don't I
and I realize they both have the same
thing in common I have no idea how
people think about me it's just the
first time it wasn't even an option for
me to try and guess then it was like I'm
trying to figure it out and I'm doing so
much work and so many questions and so
much observations and so much
calculations and I still don't know and
I realize oh there's no way for me to
know how people are thinking that
doesn't mean go do whatever I want I
want to be aware there's a line in the
sand so I don't cross it but I
everyone's line is different it's always
moving so the best I could do is just
like trust my moral compass and every
now and then check in every now and then
I still think I do it too much too many
chickens I used to say sorry so much by
the beforehand
I went into my doctor's office but this
is before my diagnosis I went into my uh
like a general practitioner
uh I was getting shoulder surgery in a
couple of days but also I was there for
something else
while I'm there when I'm talking to him
I go by the way I'm getting this
shoulder surgery and I'm asking him
questions uh maybe I don't know it
doesn't matter how many questions I ask
them a few questions and he goes I I
that's not you have to ask your surgeon
and I notice the energy shift I didn't
know what it was so I said is is it did
I bother you did something happen yeah
and he goes Rick I'm going to be honest
when I see your name on my door I take a
deep breath and I said why he goes I
only have so much time you ask me so
many questions
my thought is
actually said to him well tell me that
you you know you could tell me that but
also
you're my doctor I'm not I'm you know
I'm here to ask you questions right
he was cold I don't see this doctor
anymore but I did for a bit still hey
that's my doctor over for you I got the
autism diagnosis and I went and I told
him by the way I got this I was
diagnosed with autism and he goes that
makes so much sense and he was so nice
to me yeah he was talking to me about
baseball I don't know anything he's like
did you watch the the doors and I'm like
yeah I don't and he's just being so nice
and I realized I'm the same person he
just has a better understanding or at
least what he thinks and understanding
of me is I was so [__] frustrating to
me yeah
I'm not any different he just sees me
different yeah so me checking in
could help give me information but then
the big thing that I learned was it's
not just about in fact it's mostly not
about how you see me it's the best way
to control if I'm even going to control
how people see me if if you're trying to
find that hack is to is to not change
who I am outside of always find a way to
be your best self and I'm saying this is
who I am today is
right letting other people become aware
of their own expectations that may not
be met by me
so like if I come in and be like hey
just want you to know I do a lot of bits
yeah
I and I do a lot of bits you then could
be like Rick enough for the bits or you
you were expecting it so you're okay
even it's funny I I love all of this
self-awareness you're just such a
brilliant mind even though you do a lot
of bits I mean how many times in this
conversation have I not been sure you
were doing a bit like and I'm a comedian
I'm a silly bean yeah I'm just I'm just
going back to our original point which
is or the billboard point it's crazy
that we're all having our own experience
and can I say you also lifted a thought
from my own brain I said two days ago to
my friend Kurt I go I don't think I've
ever felt the same exact way twice in my
life because even if you're feeling like
a majority of a feeling let's say I feel
happy but like somewhere deep down
there's like horny for frogs you know
what I mean like something like
something weird is going on okay I know
so I understand something weird is going
on that was just that was just an absurd
example but like I does that do you
relate to that like if I think I'm sure
what you're connecting that to but I
don't yet
I mean I guess literally you can't feel
the exact same way the same way like no
snowflake is the same that's what I'm
saying yeah and that's what I'm I'm
relating to you I'm talking about the
liberal Elite by the way
snowflakes I knew what you meant I
thought I was on on par with what you've
been saying did it sounded like I
changed the subject no I just didn't
know what the connection you were making
was
she's just letting me know it's been 90
minutes gotcha how long do you go two
hours or is it depending we're doing a
lot these days so we've been going for
more 90. but do you want to wrap it up
I'm having a great time by the way yeah
I just like to know where we are sure
checking in making sure I didn't derail
you none okay I was just trying to say
like Rick I'm with you
the world is confusing how people feel
is confusing yeah and I also want to
just let you know that I really heard
your point that I think is a very
there's it's an emotional point is that
this doctor who was overwhelmed by you
stopped being overwhelmed by you even
though you were exactly the same yeah
just because he had a different lens to
look at you through and isn't that not
to force this
that's one of the things that's very
interesting to me about spirituality is
it's trying to put a more patient loving
compassionate understanding lens because
that lens
is everything and you know what I'm
saying like what changed like if I do a
lot of work breath work meditation
contemplation and study and then after
dinner with my parents I'll have a more
beautiful compassionate time just takes
all that effort and then you you work
that muscle so much ideally that your
lens just that's what conversion is your
your lens shifts to a new lens and now
even if I haven't had enough sleep or
enough food or my psychological physical
emotional needs met the lens remains
that's that's the long-term goal of
conversion or Enlightenment is that
you're looking through a different lens
but that that that's what I'm saying is
like we should all be
I hope that was okay it was
unintentional I'm not making fun of your
boundary issues uh boundaries same page
I'm just acknowledging them I touched
your foot
the the goal of life
to me one of them is to
be your doctor treating you
as if I already know you have autism
before I know you have autism does that
make sense I I think I like to pardon
the correction but to globalize it to
just accept this except except people
yes that's what I mean in this case
accepting you means but I also also
don't want to I don't think that the
reason he was annoyed by me is because
of autism I agree it's just whatever
character traits I have
but I have a family member who I believe
uh is on the Spectrum yeah and when I
was telling this person that I I wanted
them to get tested I was like not for
you
so these people in our family will treat
you differently we'll get off your back
there's a book I read
um it's for them it's for your doctor
forgot what it's called I'm saying it
with this what you're saying I forgot
what it's called Asperger's from the
inside out I think it's called okay
um written by a guy who was diagnosed
late in life when his son was diagnosed
um and I'm paraphrasing but there's
something in it was about
it's not just about learning how to
communicate
like oh here now I'm more in touch with
the way I think and feel it's helping
other people and teaching them how to
communicate with you yeah which is not
an Autism thing it's just that's what
getting to know people is that's what
frequency is and this has nothing to do
with I I it's not exclusive to uh
different neurotypes everybody when you
say that I'm like man I need more I need
help understanding how I'm being
understood and my own feelings and
understanding myself but you could tell
people yeah once you learn those things
you could tell people right hey do me a
favor I'm the type of person that wants
to know when they're spinach in my teeth
even if you're not somebody who tells
people now that I've told you that
you're it's going to be easier for you
yeah and I think that's what first dates
are intimate or otherwise that's like a
yep Maya Rudolph says just kidding it's
my Angela Maya Angelou says when people
tell you who they are believe them yeah
but you can go that the reverse and be
like tell people who you are
each other's sentences absolutely each
other's sandwiches um also you said
something that I wanted to touch on that
um uh that I said to somebody I was
dating
uh you said help me help me
we were having a conversation but like
what do you want what are you looking
for in a partner and one of the few
things I said other than huge tits and a
fat ass was I'm looking for somebody I'm
looking for help
I want you to help me and that doesn't I
don't mean like help me make me pack my
clothes
is like a pretty big building to drive
fast and not acknowledge it uh keep
going but I said it for coming I loved
it you know everyone had one of the two
and I either help me fat ass the huge
tits I need two of those
and um like also I want to be able to do
that that's putting the mic stand away
be careful like I like helping yeah
um
help me
I love people that help in any type of
collaboration motivation information
yeah just like you're helping me cheat
at the test of Life yeah be my
calculator help but I also don't want
somebody to feel like can I have there
I'm being real go ahead I'll say this I
don't mean like I need to rely on you to
help me I need you for this I'm saying I
want to surround myself so a friend of
mine
she said to me that she's talking about
a friendship of hers and she's like and
like she doesn't have to like offer me
value that's like I don't remember what
it was something like that like a friend
doesn't have to give you stuff and I'm
like I completely disagree anybody that
you're choosing to have in your life
needs to offer you value and you them or
there's no point of that relationship so
like I don't need you to help me because
I need help but I'm gonna choose to be
around people
make me laugh teach me something yeah
make make me inspired help make I want
to be better or I and I also say that
it's not always this is something I'm
trying to learn by observing Val and her
close friendships which I'm often very
jealous of my relationships are a little
more like what you're saying like I like
people that will uh my friend James
Bashar right who actually developed
magic mine you call James delicious by
the way I'm glad and do you feel the
little yeah I feel unbelievable I'm glad
it's incredible and I normally don't
like drinking things but when I do I do
more stress less
you do more stress less can we put a
little pause yep I
do more stress less okay that was very
funny
he's a guy that you call him and you go
I'm having an issue he solves it he
fixes it that I I consider that to be
very masculine energy it's like I see a
problem and I cut down the tree that was
blocking your view you know what I mean
if you're looking for someone to cut
down your tree of course exactly Val's
friends don't cut down each other's
trees they sit down around the tree and
have a laughter infused joyful friend
heart space this sounds like I'm going
like and it's girly I'm not at all men
can do this too I have many friends that
I do this with but Val's puts more of an
emphasis on that so when I'm like Rick
can help me make my YouTube channel a
little bit uh more views because you've
really figured that out you're a smart
marketing person that's very uh one type
of thing but then Val's been like you
also just sometimes need friends where
like what you're saying isn't even the
point you're not exchanging information
techniques tips you're not doing the Wim
Hof method you're not doing cold
exposure you're not doing intermittent
fasting and you're not meditating you're
just being there for one another going
hey I see you good job being you and
then they say hey I see you good job
being you and that's also important yeah
I'm trying to open up my circle of
friends to have more nuanced so when I
go I'm like you I want to get something
that's helped too but I'm trying to
recognize that things that don't look
like help like just sit down actually
redefining what help means because I'm
like I'm more like James I'll give you
the example that I use with James is I
was like I'm really nervous about this
live you made it weird we're doing and
uh I'm just not looking forward to it
and he was like what if my buddy Jake
who now runs my social what if Jake came
and filmed it then you could cut it
together and put on YouTube and it would
be exciting about that I was like what
the [__] what the [__] are you and he
did it worked like somebody became novel
it's got like 22 views
go check it out leave a comment to help
the algorithm leave a comment oh
but you see what I mean like he took my
anxiety and he turned it into something
to look forward to because he made it
novel and he offered help right then it
wasn't just me it was like What if we
felt how do you how would you define
help
I mean that's what that's I guess that's
what we're talking about is there's lots
of different ways sometimes help is
literally just sitting around not
helping you but being a warm body that's
like yeah I'm here too this is a
confusing Place could you try and Define
it um without an example
what help is like to me I would say it's
I am better off after I feel better
things became easier I got something
accomplished whatever it might be yeah
from before the help to after and that
could just be acknowledging the thing
I'm glad this happened it filled me
didn't join me you know what's funny
help is very similar to love because
love is me seeing your needs as my needs
your your feelings your desires your
life as my life saying it it's like
removing the separation unfortunately we
can't do it quite perfectly I can do it
easier with Val and certainly my
daughter than you can with me well yeah
you and I there's effort to remember
that deep deep down you and I are the
same the same thing and when I remember
that it's even helpful to just say it I
remember like boy I hope Rick's enjoying
the podcast I feel bad about saying the
mirror thing I'm just kidding but like
that that's a loving thing and it's very
similar to help help and lover I can't
say they're synonymous but they're very
very similar okay I'll say they're
synonymous just because it's fun to say
synonymous yeah synonymous
I remain anonymous when I'm synonymous
with being a guy who goes into
McDonald's then I get some bigger prize
I wish something else rhymed with fries
no nothing lies
I told lies
you're self-covered in flies right now
I feel us winding down but I also feel
myself I don't want to end now that
could be two minutes from now don't
worry
what do you here's how we end do you
have any thoughts on tell me oh you oh
God can I tell you this I always hated
this because I'm on my way to see her
get out I think God's a woman that's
totally fine I'm just over thinking that
that's just the most precocious thing
that was the 90s it kind of was a woman
being like let's all pray to God and see
if she you know like that's like that's
over in 1997 that was like what did you
say I'm just happy to say that's no
longer blowing as many Lids as it used
to be believe me if God was a man
you know
but God is a woman yeah because look how
beautiful you know yeah there it is
that's why I do it I like that any
thoughts on God do you believe in a
source I try not to talk about other
people
that's very funny thank you
do you subscribe to any belief system
I mean yeah spiritual wise
yeah it changes all the time
it does
um
looking for meaning in things versus
accepting that there isn't
uh
are those different because
then it's like where those where that
Venn diagram overlaps would be you get
to create your own meaning for things
um
like things have meaning because you
give them meaning yeah it's like why did
this happen or what's the point of this
versus it's all arbitrary and there is
no point of this to where those what
those two things have in common are
either if there's a point I could find
what it is and if there isn't I get to
make what it is either way there is a
point but by Design then there's a good
chance there isn't one
so like I'm here to connect with a
friend I'm here to uh uh promote a
podcast I'm here because I need reasons
to get out of the house I mean all of
them I don't know if this is here to
promote my podcast necessarily I would
take your shoes off yeah but nobody's
watching and but they're listening oh my
God I forgot about that yeah there you
go
um but like that to me is is feels
somewhat spiritual because when you get
to assign meaning to things
it's like I'm making a choice that other
people if I make the choice that other
people have made like this is the best
version of this so why is this the best
version of this
uh interesting I don't know I just think
God's a woman
do you think when you die you're over
I I don't I don't know I don't I don't
know
um
that's a great answer you don't have to
you don't have to dig around for more
and uh do you do you want to move
there's another question after the god
question but I don't want to move too
quickly through it
good
do you want more God time
are we all
time is an illusion I don't believe that
I don't believe time is an illusion
anymore than I think
you know
this is that's great thank you we'll
we'll speed it up oh a flame I'm gonna
make an eternal flame coming from your
fingertips people really should be
watching this on YouTube a lot of fizzy
bits well that's the thing uh one thing
I have learned to appreciate is facial
expressions yeah yeah more than ever as
an adult I missed the term aspie it was
so fun wow he was a Nazi probably still
is Asperger yeah is that why we stopped
using it that and I don't have a a I
don't have a take on this this is just
what it is
um it was also there's an effort to
destigmatize the difference between
saying high functioning versus low
functioning as if to say that high
functioning would be better than low
functioning and to hide functioning
high functioning versus low uh low
functioning
um that's a visual gag yeah and um uh
and also that's why they switch it to
those like Asperger's what was known as
Asperger's is now considered level one
autism so like it's one two three free
not high low there's three rakes uh
there's there's three oh no uh
three the German three yeah do you learn
that from uh glorious bastards same
that's our YouTube Instagram clip right
there you can mark that that's great
um I just have to call it out what were
we talking about why we don't say
Asperger's anymore oh yeah so and also
there's uh uh you know he was a Nazi
right
um and did studies on people and decided
whether or not well this version is okay
these people could live versus others I
see yeah all right I'm I'm convinced I'm
not offended by the term and also I I
just wish you could say autistee or
something a casual way no what I'm
saying about what I like about aspie is
there was like a playful light way of
saying a lot like it's a little aspy but
I feel this way or whatever like it made
it light well ever since that ABC show
we could Now call it uh autistic
autistic yeah okay
um when I talked about this on my
podcast there are people in the comments
that go off on either end of this which
is
you can't say this you shouldn't say
this this isn't what it is anymore and
then people like yeah but it's a
shorthand people know what Asperger's is
they may not accept or understand autism
because they think of it as something
different and like it I'm fine with this
I'm not fine with this and it's just
like like I said I don't have skin in
the game I reckon it's it's I think it's
similar psychology as far as how people
receive it to this uh this battle of the
pronouns it's like if you want to be
called that fine if you don't care then
fine but to have stakes and be like you
have to do this or not I at least just
to be candid I don't I don't yeah I
understand what you're saying yeah
here's the last and final question and
it's more fun are you excited
have you ever seen a ghost
have you ever seen a UFO
probably everything I see that I don't
know what it is right that's in the air
if it's flying yeah yeah what's the time
you've laughed the hardest in your life
and here's a few
it's like a guided hypnosis session
ghs Jesus ghs JHS guys ghs
sorry forgot as your lawyer I'm gonna
Sue myself
um who by the way I think there should
be more women lawyers
but when we have our daughters we tell
them they're going to be princesses and
we need to teach them how to code and to
you know that they're able to do just as
much to be honest with you I think more
I think women are better than men
okay
it's a little suspicious that you're so
grotesquely siding with the species the
staff of the species that you want to
mate with but yeah I don't want to mate
with half the women in the world just
the ones that have either two of the
following three
preferably okay maybe preferably I also
forgot pretty face
so far
um maybe you were a kid maybe someone
fell down he was maybe someone farted
maybe you were on drugs uh
uh and I'm gonna be honest my least
favorite dancers are when it's a movie
so did you ever see someone fall in a
fountain or Step Brothers man when I
watched and he goes when he's putting
the ketchup on his plate he goes I like
it no that's not where I live um the
balls on the TomTom is funnier than that
okay uh
okay Jesus there is a time that comes to
mind but it's never nobler
to search to find to to understand the
difference between time and space to to
live in a moment that is written but
I I it could be erased you know like
like think about it this way there's you
see yourself in the mirror the Lord
above it seems so clear the vision of
you is is nothing more to see than a
than a vision of Illusion of a place to
be inside of me it's it's different to
be
but when I farted in a microphone once
it made me laugh so hard
I um I've done it three times
I've done it three times on stage three
times and every time I've done it I
didn't know I was going to do it I felt
a thin and then I just did it I thought
you're gonna do it um that would have
been a first and I couldn't recover I
couldn't I was oh I couldn't stop was
the audience also laughing no see that's
back to your thing
um
yeah coincidentally because also like
it's not gross to me right so it's your
own fart yeah but there's something the
whole thing is what's so funny there's
something about have you ever farted or
heard a fart in a microphone in a room
with speakers it's [__] insane it's
insane because it sounds just like a
fart but you've never heard it before
you've never heard it that way before
you've never heard it so
three-dimensionally also you did it also
you're in the audience too because you
didn't plan it also you seeing the
people not receiving it which nor do
they need to but it's just like
and when I did it every time I tried to
do it as a throwaway
and then just continue going and I
couldn't stop laughing
also farts are funny yes uh I've talked
about this on my pod but I do think
there is a direct correlation to people
that find farts funny are good people
because there is a child like I agreeing
with them where they are okay with and
they get it I just was hearing about the
Dalai Lama he was on a talk show and
they were asking him about she's doing
my bit did he fart he did your bit no go
ahead he did he was talking about the
difference between the sacred and the
profane or finding the sacred in the
everyday and the Dalai Lama
sacred versus the profane yeah what does
profane mean just means like farting
that's profane the difference between
this what's sacred and what's blue
Blue Streak uh is what well that's a lot
of spiritual people are trying to say
there is no difference
so the Dalai Lama goes on and with tears
rolling down his face talking about how
funny farting is
and the ho and the people interviewing
them are like aghast and he's unattended
not intended good thank you for thank
you for admitting that yeah a lot of
people say pun intended and I go you
would have delivered it different that's
right if you intended there's a Twist
you give a pun he's talking about how
you lift up on One Cheek on an airplane
to let it out sneaky dying laughing yeah
and the Dalai Lama is a good person I'm
with you if you think farts are funny
yeah you're probably a good person
you're like an honest person yeah it's
completely it's a good it's a it's a
small sample but it's like it's a
starting off point I agree me and my
friend Aaron Aaron we used to be on the
phone just long hours just talking do
you think if we had a fart would fart in
the phone yeah but then we've talked
about this before but we would fake it a
lot too we and would try and get away
with it but then the bit you'd love this
became doing one that is so clearly fake
so you're on the phone and you're like
oh hold on hold on
[Laughter]
and he'd come back and you go that's not
genuine that's what we would say
I just thought you'd like that I do like
it okay good
um before we go while we're talking
about puns I want to show you a
character I've been working on okay it's
a guy who really likes the idea of puns
because he sees how much people love
them and he wants to do them so he does
the thing is he doesn't understand how
puns work okay okay here it is um let's
just say you would understand
what I was talking about if I did it
no but all jokes aside uh Pete I had a
really fun time
podcasting with you
uh pun intended but I did that on
purpose
or should I say I did that on purpose
Oh you mean like a cat I don't get it
anyway uh thanks for having me
here
this episode of uh make it weird with
Pete Holmes is sponsored by Marshall rug
gallery and the take your shoes off
podcast thank you is there anything you
want to plug by the way I feel like I
should plug tanks a lot oil tank removal
service in the Greater Boston area it's
my dad's business
um if you're looking to convert your
home from oil
right if it's in your basement I want to
into gas
tanks a lot home tank removal company
we'll dig that thing out or get it out
of your basement and convert it all up I
have a question that maybe this is
something for your dad to answer okay
but with the name of his company was the
pun intended
or did he spell it wrong this is and
Commit This is real that was really it
like took my breath away I'm not
laughing because it was just we were on
the topic of podcast and my dad's
company is a pun
and my dad never writes thanks he writes
tanks so the answer is I don't know
I'd like that I like when people would
say
um tanks uh tanks for the good time yeah
I don't know if the pun was intended
tanks yeah I'm saying just to say that
but if my dad removes your oil tank and
he goes thank you he definitely intended
that yeah if you did intend it guess who
drew the logo for sir tanks a lot
I'm pointing at him
Rick oh you yeah oh that's pointing out
you give me a hint I'd like to redo it
it's very College Pete modern Pete would
do it a little more elegantly
do it okay well
will you
close us out by saying no
by saying
as your lawyer isn't that what you say
when your buddy's saying is leaving
by saying
edit that out go ahead
saying Ralph Waldo where is Ralph Waldo
he's always standing he's always
standing around other people with
stripes you know transcending
would you say keep it crispy it's how we
end keep it crispy
there it is and as always
keep it crispy
sandwiches for all the times
[Applause]
you're everything I am because you look
at love me she is crispy these are ISO
tracks okay yeah lower his keep it
crazy do it again the way you just did
it keep it crispy
[Music]